[Music]
i covered this recently on the ken
coleman show and this is what's going on
in corporate america and it just happens
john that this example comes from the
largest company in the world or one of
them okay how about that awesome have
you heard of the company called amazon
tell me about it yeah yeah apparently
they ship you anything you want is it a
it's a i thought it was like a like a
river cleanup company no no no they got
all the products and all the stuff
anyway here's the deal this is from vox
recent article john um
amazon is facing a looming crisis they
could run out of people to hire in their
u.s warehouses by 2024. this is
according to a leaked
internal research project
from amazon this is middle of last year
the leaked findings also
serve as a potential cautionary tale for
other employers who are trying to do the
churn and burn
metrics metrics metrics
we don't care if you got to go potty you
got to stand there and get the package
filled in three minutes or less amazon
rules a lot of companies are trying to
emulate them because the stock price is
obviously there well the rest of the
story is is they're churning through
people at an alarming rate and the point
is this internal study was to highlight
hey
we're burning through people so quickly
we're going to run out of that
demographic that we need in the
warehouse
so this is a real crisis now this is
what i want you to comment on um hey can
we just real quick before we get there
yeah think of this sentence
it could run out of people to hire in
its u.s warehouses
by 2024.
my first initial thought is well if your
place was worth working yet you wouldn't
well you're exactly right that's my
first oh yeah what do you mean we're
going to run you mean you're going to
run out of people who are going to take
your crap that's exactly right and live
substandard to be treated terribly then
that's like
your wife's going to quit going out with
you yeah right yeah it's not a her issue
yeah it's a youtube because i'm not
worth going out with yeah jeez luigi
yeah and so that's why this is a crisis
right now this is their response to this
so amazon spokespeople said the company
will count on natural attrition rates to
solve their current overstaffing problem
now i want to break that down because
there's a lot of big words there
attrition overstaffing so here's what
that means folks listen to this amazon
overhired
during
2021 obviously people were spending
money like crazy now we're starting to
see consumer spending slow down a little
bit
so they've got too many people so
instead of treating those folks with
dignity
and say hey we overstaffed we're in a
downturn
and you're part of a layoff this sucks
like normal companies would do
they're saying no
we're gonna let our normal burn rate
which means burning through people
burning them out to the point where they
go screw this i can't do it anymore i
quit
that's how they're going to
downsize their employee group or taking
800 of them and putting them in a room
and saying look
we we need particularly need help in
phoenix and so we're offering this bonus
to move people to phoenix we're offering
this bonus to move people to fill in the
blank here right but no we're just gonna
let we're gonna we're gonna turn the
oxygen down
and let those of you who pass out and
don't make it that's exactly gonna solve
our problems so and this is this is on
the heels of bezos earlier this year
jeff bezos is saying we want to be the
number one company to work at in the
world and their internal memo is going
hey hello a lot of people we're going to
screw ourselves
by burning through people too quickly
and they look at their current thing and
they go that's fine
we'll just burn people out now this is
the other thing john that that that i
want you to comment on so i want you to
that that view of people i'm just
curious your take coming from the world
you come from uh when leaders view
people as just this
i don't even know if you can view people
as assets and then
they have more workplace injuries than
any other company
by miles they've led the country
in injury incidents
largely in warehouses
the pressure on the warehouse worker
from the time that john delaney orders
something from your house
in fairview to the time it goes to
whatever warehouse how quickly has to be
filled and they don't let people take
breaks i mean it is close to
uh
really unhealthy unsafe conditions
because they're burning through people
what what's going on in a company like
that how do they look at people for real
not what they tell us so i think first
there's a disconnect between the lived
lives of your employees and that
spreadsheet that's telling you you're
doing a good job
and that's always a recipe for
short-term gain
long-term fall off a cliff right the
more you focus on how happy am i right
now right now
i'm just gonna keep eating twinkies i'm
gonna keep not exercising i'm gonna
watch another movie i'm gonna do this
that's gonna you're gonna feel good for
a while you are
and you're gonna wake up and you're
gonna be way overweight you're gonna
feel awful and your friends will have
left you and you're gonna all right
you're gonna wake up in ashes and this
tells me that this is a company that has
gotten rich like you said it best really
excited by
the applause at the shareholder meeting
and they have forgotten that there is a
whole bunch of people responsible for
that applause
and
at some point they cross paths right and
i mean this is just a
control burn that's
that's that's left that's left the
control burn area and it's heading off
into to set the wilderness on fire
here's the deal folks it's gonna be a
mess yeah the reason we share this is
because you got amazon workers who will
put up with us for a while then they
leave and you don't have to put up with
this you don't have to put up with this
stuff you know and when you're in an
organization that uh will not value
people they they value process over
people i've got news for you they're not
going to change
they will just keep going and keep going
until it's too late and this by the way
is how the mighty fall
i am in no predicting amazon's demise
but i'm telling you
that's a four-alarm warning right there
coming from an internal memo right and
the fact is they're treating people like
absolute garbage i reported yesterday on
on the ken coleman show there's a
company of that uh a 15 billion dollar
company that does food orders and
they've hired amazon execs who've come
in and changed it and you're ready for
this they they got they got disciplined
one of the managers warehouse managers
got disciplined
because the evening before
a package was not packed in three
minutes
because the employee went to the
bathroom for a few minutes i read the
email on the show
the the the higher up comes in the next
day and sends an email and says what are
we going to do about this how do we
anticipate this gee i don't know how do
we anticipate when one of our people has
to go poo less water less water right
how do we walk around going what'd you
have for lunch today exactly did you oh
you ate mexican was it a burrito are you
feeling gassy
do you think you have to go poo poo
later today and when you go how long are
you gonna go for there's just gonna be
somebody knocking on the door on the
outside yeah you're done you're done
you're done come on richard
what are we doing here right but it is
that type of monitoring in the name of
efficiency
it's become nanny ship john
not leadership
yeah nanny ship i mean we monitored our
kids when they were little right when it
was nap time oh you know look at ty he's
not going to sleep but look look at
what's happening with the kid you know
it's helicopter parenting except it's
helicopter bossing that's it and look
we've destroyed a generation of human
being by helicopter parents it's the
truth and we're doing it to our workers
and that's the reason you get people to
buy into your mission come on and let
them feel valued like they're
contributing to the society at large and
then they will you'll have a hard time
you know getting rid of them yeah
they'll stay forever yeah to all the
amazon execs why don't you try loving
your people
why don't you try loving them oh ken
you're so dumb you don't know i know oh
you're a softie
oh my gosh excuse me can't go to the
bathroom oh hey you only have two
minutes